video i want to tackle an entire ap
macroeconomics free response exercise
with you
assume that the economy of country x has
an actual unemployment rate of seven
percent a natural rate of unemployment
of five percent and an inflation rate of
three percent using the numerical values
given above draw a correctly labeled
graph of the short run and long run
phillips curves label the current short
run equilibrium as point b plot the
numerical values above on the graph so
pause this video if you are inspired to
do so but i will now work through it
so remember phillips curves show the
relationship or the theoretical
relationship between the unemployment
rate and the inflation rate so i'm going
to do the inflation rate
inflation
inflation rate in the vertical axis
which is typical
and then on the horizontal axis i am
going to do
my unemployment rate
so this is going to be my unemployment
unemployment
rate
which is going to be a percentage
now we want to graph the short run and
long run phillips curves let's do the
long run first because we've seen before
the long run just sets our unemployment
rate at the natural rate of unemployment
and it isn't related to our inflation
rate it'll just be a vertical line and
so it'll be a vertical line at our
natural rate of unemployment which is 5
so maybe it looks just like this
so i could call that our long run
phillips curve
and it's going to be right there at five
percent
and i'm gonna now have to do the short
run phillips curve and that will show a
relationship between inflation rate and
unemployment and just think about what's
going on if you have a low rate of
unemployment especially if it's below
your natural rate of unemployment well
then there's a lot of demand for people
and so people say hey if you want me to
work you got to pay me a little bit more
and so that could just lead to a higher
inflation rate and then if a lot of
people are unemployed they might be
willing to work for less or they might
have less money in their pocket with
which to drive up prices and so you will
have this inverse relationship right
over here so this is the short run
phillips curve which is downward sloping
and then they say label the short run
equilibrium as point b
so let's say this is point b right over
here and they say the short run
equilibrium we have an unemployment rate
of seven percent and an inflation rate
of three percent so our unemployment
rate right over here is seven percent
and our inflation rate
right over here is three percent all
right let's do the next section
assume that the government of country x
takes no policy action to reduce
unemployment
in the long run which of the following
shift to the right shift to the left or
remain the same
so here they're saying short run
aggregate supply curve explain
so here it's kind of tricky because you
might be thinking they're asking about
what you just drew but here they're
talking about aggregate supply so let me
draw a graph to even help visualize this
so if we're talking about aggregate
demand and aggregate supply our vertical
axis is going to be our price level i'll
just call that pl
and our horizontal axis that is going to
be our real gdp
so this is real
gdp right over here gdp
now you're just going to have a long run
supply curve which is vertical
that's just the full employment output
for our country so that's the long run
aggregate supply but what about the
short run aggregate supply curve
well that's going to be upward sloping
if price levels are low people might not
be willing to output a lot and if price
levels are high people will output more
so our short run
aggregate supply
would look like that i'll call that sub
1 since we're going to think about how
it shifts and then aggregate demand
would look something like this
let me draw it like
that and notice our equilibrium point
right over here let me call that
aggregate demand right over here let's
call that y sub 1 and we are at
price level sub 1. i drew it to the left
of the long run aggregate supply curve i
drew it to the left of the full
employment output because we are dealing
with a recession here our unemployment
rate is higher than the natural level of
unemployment so if our actual
unemployment rate is higher than the
natural rate of unemployment what will
happen to the short-run aggregate supply
so one way to think about it at a given
price level because there's people out
there looking for a job you might be
able to get more output or at for a
given amount of output it might cost
less because there's just people out
there competing for that work
and so you would have your short run
aggregate supply curve shift to the
right short run aggregate supply sub 2
and then your equilibrium price level
would go down price level sub 2 would go
down so we could say
because
of high unemployment
high
unemployment
employment
that could apply wage pressure we could
say wages come down
wages come
down
which
would
shift
the short run aggregate supply curve
to
the right
and there's a couple of ways to think
about that you would have more output
more output
at
a given
given
price level you could also think at a
given output level you would have a
lower price level
at a given price level
part two long run phillips curve so
that's this vertical line right over
here and the thing to appreciate is
these long run the long run phillips
curve or the long run aggregate supply
curve these don't change unless
something structurally changes in the
economy unless the economy changes in
some very fundamental way maybe a change
in education levels change in population
a change in technology and so here we
would say it just remains the same
remains
remains the same
all right
we have more parts here
now let's go to
part
c
identify a fiscal policy action that
could be used to reduce the unemployment
rate in the short run so you have to be
very careful here they're saying a
fiscal policy action not a monetary
policy if you said hey we would change
the federal funds rate or we would
increase the money supply or decrease
the money supply those would be monetary
actions we care about a fiscal policy
action and this would be in relation to
lowering taxes or raising taxes or
increasing or decreasing government
spending
well if we want to reduce the
unemployment weight rate one way to do
that would be to shift aggregate demand
to the right and one way to do that
would be to put more money in people's
pockets and one way to do that is to
have a tax cut tax
cut
a tax cut all right
draw a correctly labeled graph of
aggregate demand and short run aggregate
supply and show the impact on the
equilibrium price level and real gdp of
the fiscal policy action identified in
part c all right let me draw that
so this is
going to be so that we have our price
level axis up here and we just drew
something very similar to this
real gdp
and now let's draw our short run
aggregate supply which we have seen
before that would be upward sloping as
the price level increases people would
or the economy might be willing to
output more so that short run
aggregate supply and then let's draw an
aggregate demand curve so
let's call that a d
sub 1
and then you have the equilibrium output
let's call that y sub 1 and you have
your equilibrium
price level pl sub 1. and now if you
have a tax cut that would shift
aggregate demand to the right at any
given price level people are going to
want more they're going to demand more
because now they have more money in
their pockets and so it's going to shift
to the right so i'll do a aggregate
demand sub 2 and now we have a different
equilibrium real gdp so that is going to
be y sub 2 and it happens and then we
have price level sub 2. so you see our
price level goes up and our aggregate
output our gdp our real gdp goes up as
well
based on the change in real gdp
identified in part d will the supply of
country x's currency in the foreign
exchange market increase decrease or
remain the same
explain
the way i think about it is if you have
real gdp increasing you're in a
situation where you just have more
economic activity the national income
has gone up and if national income has
gone up people are going to do a lot
more of everything including buying
imports and to buy imports they would
have to increase the supply of their
currency and exchange markets because
they want to convert it into foreign
currencies to buy those imports and so
this will increase
increase
and we could say because
because national income
national income
has gone up
has
gone
up
people
[Music]
will
buy more imports
buy
more imports
so the supply
supply
of
country x's currency for exchange will
go up
currency
x is
for
exchange
will
go
up
all right part f based on your answer to
part e and assume a flexible exchange
rate system will country x's currency
appreciate depreciate or remain the same
in the foreign exchange market
well if you hold all else equal but you
increase the supply of something well
then the price of it is going to go down
if the demand for it stays constant but
you increase the supply and that's what
we just talked about in part e well then
the price is going to go down and when
if we're talking about the price of a
currency we would and we're saying it's
going down we would say that that
currency is depreciating so it would
depreciate
and we're done